good evening symma tog refers and film
in general have a tremendous debt - oh
and Royce Minh in the early 70s owen
shattered that notion that a successful
movie had to be shot in a traditional
Hollywood style well he figured out how
to achieve an intense realism using soft
light not in the controlled studio
setting but permit primarily on location
which is really much more challenging
Odin wanted to create images in an
overall look that was relevant in
organic to the story and characters but
which were also beautiful and he managed
to do that using the tools of that pre
digital era including film which was way
less sensitive to light than what it is
today
another thing I have to thank Owen for
is that he's responsible for me seeing
my first r-rated movie it was a French
Connection and I somehow managed to uh
yeah when I am younger than you I
managed to convince my parents to take
me to see that one and also my second
r-rated movie was the Exorcist which I
had to sneak into I was riveted you know
in the first case and riveted but also
petrified in the second one you know but
these films you know when I was a kid
these films were the films which
actually I noticed what cinematography
did with a movie story they made they
back then they made other movies seem
phony and kind of staged because Owens
movies just engaged you on such a
visceral level Owen has always been a
determined visionary and competitive
artist but he's also the most gracious
modest and generous person you'll ever
meet
I suppose you know we're honoring you
tonight Owen but truly I think your
award honors us
on behalf of the governors of the
Academy congratulations
[Applause]